Let's touch base with our color from the five
one seven area code before we run out of time.
Who's calling today from five one seven five
one seven.
Are we muted?
No, you're not.
What's going on?
Five one seven.
[inaudible] are you there David?
Yes, I am.
You there, David?
Uh, hi.
I was calling in today to ask you, what do
you think we can do to combat cognitive dissonance
within the liberal party, the liberal.
And I find that whenever a lot of people like
that last call, or bringing facts to people,
if they talk red mining, if you want to bring
up Obama droning the hell out of the middle
East and starting new legal Wars, if you want
to bring up the poisoning of our water for
four decades, three decades, excuse me, three
decades by almost every single president with
open munitions burnings, people just closed
down.
It's not just the right, like people want
to think the left is in a state right now.
We're, we're closing down as well.
We don't want to hear the facts if they don't
conform to our worlds.
Do you want our bubbles?
So what can we do on the left to try to bring
our own side back to, I might not like these
facts, but the facts.
Yeah.
Listen, I mean, I, we can only do this at
the individual level.
Uh, I regularly make it a point on this program
to say I'm on the left.
The program leans left.
I think that the left is right on way more
issues than the right.
But there's issues where Republicans and Democrats
are both guilty of almost the same thing to
almost the exact same extent.
I mean, you can't do anything other than to
tell the truth.
And this is more of a, of a behavioral economics
issue.
It's a psychology issue.
It's more than partisan.
But being aware of it is step one and step
two is pointing it out when we see it.
And you know, I try to do that every day.
So do you think that there's much hope for
things getting better?
Yeah, I have hope.
I mean that's one issue where I am optimistic.
I think if we go back to teaching critical
thinking, uh, at an early age, if we teach
civics and philosophy starting in middle school,
I think that we will predispose people to
be less, um, uh, subject to the cognitive
dissonance you're talking about.
That's my hope.
Where I would argue with you that you can
look in, people are willing to voice them.
They're willing to put their wait, wait.
They're willing to what?
Okay.
It looked like he said willing.
Did he say willing to drink poison?
I don't know.
This is a problem.
I'm trying to deal with it here and it requires
some bigger systemic solutions.
That's all the time I have today.
Sorry to everybody.
I didn't get to quick rake much more right
after that.